Okay, I don't think anybody knew his odds, so we're going to jump right to the questions and get started. So here's question number one. Another practitioner is pushing for me to do missile toll.
I have heard good things, but not sure if we can financially swing it right now, but the protocol you have beyond you feel we could restore by health in time.
So I think this person is choosing to do chemotherapy as well, so I don't go that I would add missile toll at this time.
So yeah, I think this might be actually a folder question too, but I think this is something that you could forego right now. This isn't something that I don't think you need to do.
Go back to my oncologist of the week, is there an alternative treatment for Xomena. So Xomena is the drug that is in injection to for people who have the tassysis to the bone.
So I've spoken a lot of this in the past, and I am very much not a fan of this drug. So I can't tell a person to take it or not to take it, but I'm not a fan of this drug because of the studies on the drug itself.
They're just so unfavorable, but they continue to use it, which is kind of mind-boggling to me.
So here's the deal with Xomena. So when it first came out, it was a drug for osteoporosis. So if you have osteoporosis, they put you on Xomena, or I can't remember what the other brand name at the time was.
It's an older drug. It's been out at least 15 years.
And it was just this great promise that it's going to help women with osteoporosis because if you have osteoporosis, you have weakening of the bone, and then you end up with pathological fractures.
You know, you might have a mother who had a hip fracture, while a person who has a hip fracture didn't fall down and fracture their hip.
They're hip fractured, causing them to fall down, and they're hip fractured because the neck of the fever is the weakest part of the bone of the weight-bearing part of the whole fever, that neck of the fever.
And the strength of a bone is in the inner part called the endostium. The outer part of the bone is called the periostium.
Peri means outer, and means inner and osteoom. The inner part of the bone is really where the density of minerals are.
And that's what gives the strength to the bone endostium.
Well, if I have a lytic destruction of a bone due to, due to, it will start eroding away the periostium and the endostium.
Well, that's not good because that can cause, you know, weakening of the bone, and if it's a weight-bearing bone, you can end up with a pathological fracture.
If you have a pathologist to a rib, the chance to be having a pathological fracture because the ribs aren't weight-bearing, are sliver.
Though you have a lot of muscle pull on a rib, and you can fracture a rib, but it's more so, you'll, more so get a pathological fracture rib, if you like, hit it, if you fall or you beg it against something.
You could have pathological fractures are going to be, due to the tassysis, the bone are going to be in the spine.
It can be in the hip, but usually you don't have the tassysis to the fever of the hip, so you typically won't have that.
You get the tassysis to the pelvis, which it's a very big and dense bone, the chance of you having a pathological fracture there is pretty small.
It's really the spine that you're worried about.
Whether you have osteoporosis causing weakening in the bone, and then possible pathological fracture, or you have a tassysis, you want to try to strengthen up the bone.
How do you deal with when you have a tassysis in the bone? Well, you have to try to attack the cancer so that the cancer stops growing, right? That's number one.
And then from the medical doctor's perspective is, hey, we have this drug that was approved for osteoporosis, this somenna.
Why can't we use it for metastatic cancers when you have meds to the bone? Well, great. We'll start using it.
The problem is the five-year studies, which came out about 10 years ago on this drug, showed that women that used it for osteoporosis had no less pathological fractures than women that didn't use the drug.
What the heck? Well, that's what it was trying to prevent is pathological fractures. Well, all the studies, and you could Google this, Google these studies.
All the studies show that all it did is increase the density of the perilostium, not the endostium.
Well, even the authors of the study said that it literally is like wrapping saran wrap around the bone.
So it's causing the periostium to become harder, and actually, in their words, more brittle.
They're preventing calcium and minerals to get into the endostium.
So it's causing a hard, brittle, cellophane raptor, saran wrapped periostium, which the periostium doesn't give the strength to the bone.
Therefore, it doesn't actually prevent pathological fractures.
Well, why in the world are they still using a drug to prevent pathological fractures when it doesn't prevent pathological fractures because there's a whole lot of money in it.
And I don't mean to be cynical, but I have this totally against Zilbeta and the other brand names of this drug that does not increase the density of the endostium.
Actually, it prevents the increase of density of the endostium because it wraps a brittle, you know, wrap basically of calcium around the periostium, sealing it up the bones are living matrix.
And calcium is going in and out of your bones all the time. That's what helps balance your blood.
It's one of your buffering system. So you don't become acidosis is it steals calcium from the bones calcium is going in and out of the bones you have osteoclastic and osteoblastic activity constantly.
So I personally would not do Zilbeta. I would not use any of the classic drugs if I even if I had very serious.
Metastasis to the bone and weight-barried bone I would not do it. And then I would do radiation to the bone to kill the cancer if I had serious metastasis to the spine.
I would not use any of this classic drugs. Do you have to be on hormone blockers with breast cancer treatments I really hate to go back on either one of these.
Well, hormone blockers with breast cancer if you have really aggressive breast cancer has been shown to to decrease it. So I would say this I know who asked this question.
I would say yes, you should go on that. This is the same person asked this question. I would say you need to do your studies of the Zilbeta.
Personally, I wouldn't go on that. But personally, I think this might be the right thing to do right now.
I was tested for Hashimoto's about 27 years ago and had the antibody. So.
Hashimoto's is when you develop antibodies to the thyroid globulin cells. So you got thyroid globulin antibodies or thyroid globulin proxidase cells, which are TPO antibodies.
So those are two different antibodies that you would test in a person's blood and if they were elevated, you have Hashimoto's.
Well, you have either Hashimoto's or Graves disease. So if you have a spike to T3 be strongly elevated T3 with elevated or thyroid globulin antibodies, then you have Graves disease.
If you have normal or low T3.
Then you have Hashimoto's. So it's very common in Hashimoto's. So I had been tested again until last May and did not have any antibodies.
The doctor told me that I either never had it or I had it under control very well.
Just recently, I read that if you have cancer diagnosis, these antibodies don't show up as this true.
No, I don't think that's true. I've never read anything about that. It is if you have your Hashimoto's under control, your antibodies can go back down to normal.
So if you ever had elevated antibodies, you definitely had Hashimoto's. But remember autoimmune disease is diagnosed in three phases.
So if you have elevated antibodies, but you don't have any really bad symptoms.
This shows up on blood work meeting. So if you're diagnosing autoimmune disease, show up on blood work where you don't have any bad symptoms or you don't have any tissue destruction, that's in what's called silent autoimmunity or phase one stage one autoimmunity. And that's probably what you were in.
And you know, you can get that under control and you can put it in remission. So you can cure an autoimmune disease, but you can put it in remission for a long long time.
So that's probably what's going on. You know, when you were diagnosed with cancer, you're made a lot of dietary changes. You made different lifestyle changes and that can really calm down and autoimmune disease too. So that's good news.
Listening to a podcast that said cancer is just parasites. If you clean up the parasites, you can restore your health. What are your thoughts on this?
Well, I totally disagree with that. So and I would be careful listening to anybody out there that says, says dogmatic statements like that because cancer is, you know, every different type of cancer is really a different disease ever one.
And has different cause. You could have a twin brother that has the exact same cancer that you do and it could be totally different cause and totally different way to correct it.
Whatever you see, like, oh, cancer is just a fungus, you know, somebody wrote a book or two cancer isn't even a disease. It's just a fungus and you have to kill the fungus. It's just to me, those are just showing a person's ignorance, I don't know, sorry, but totally disagree with that.
Can parasites be a part of your ill health? Well, sure you can have parasites being part of ill health, no matter what kind of disease process or symptom pattern that you have. So you do want to address that too.
Have a reading that beta glue can is very good to help kill cancer cells. If so, is there a brand you would recommend maybe it is in something I've taken, I just don't see it in the gradient list. So beta glue can is polysaccharide.
So polysaccharides are probably my favorite thing to help stimulate your immune system and kill cancer cells.
And because wordy find polysaccharides, the polysaccharides are in mushrooms, polysaccharides are in aloe and different chains of polysaccharides do different things.
That's why there's using different mushrooms can be beneficial.
At the aloe via immune product that
A number of people are on. That's a certain chain of polysaccharides. I think it's around three to 400 chains, saccharide legs.
There's different chains of polysaccharides that are in chaga mushrooms and little bit different chains that are in turkey tail mushrooms and
So you can also get polysaccharides and beta glue can is just another polysaccharide. So beta glue cans are a polysaccharide that are in mushrooms. You could also get beta glue cans from other sources as well.
So if you're taking a mushroom in anything you're taking, you are getting beta glue cans. If you want a pure just straight great beta glue can.
My favorite now is the US enzymes beta glue can product.
That's called I think that's called a mudozyme.
That's a good beta glue can product.
But so if you want to take another supplement, I would look at that.
I during my phone call with Dr. Conner's couple weeks ago, he told me to send another cheek swab after my surgery, which was on Thursday.
April 6th. So it's April 19th now. So I just don't recall if I could send it in immediately or it's supposed to wait a certain time. So if your surgery was on the sixth, we were two weeks past.
Go ahead and find the segment. This would be a good time.
I just read an email that you sent about genetics protein and cancer. I had my genetics done with you and I'm wondering how I can find out if I should be eating protein or not.
I do have the MAT gene defect and the on and was told to be on a low with high any diet or the PDH gene defect and be on a low carb diet.
So if you want to schedule a time with me to chat about your genetics again, if you can't find the genetic readout. Now this person did a genetic workup with us, you know, this person started with us a long time ago.
So I'm pretty sure we weren't doing the same thing that we're doing now as far as now we give a, a, we give you the whole report, which now is like 250 pages.
And since that's so hard to digest, we give a genetic summary report, which we have printed out and we highlight the genes that we think are the ones of concern. And that is about, I don't know, 15 to 18 pages. And then you really only have to look at the highlighted genes, which might be only five or six genes that are really a concern.
And now we also give a genetic action step report that is like, OK, really that's the only thing you really need to look at unless you want to dig in a little bit deeper with the summary report.
If you want to totally geek out on the, on the phone one and then follow that along with going to the reader genes course and watch all the videos that.
And I have created on the genetics through the reader genes course so.
But if you just want to know, hey, I just want to know if I have this gene defect that I can't figure it out, looking at my big report, then call and schedule a time to go over with me, just try to have your questions organized because it can be a lot of meat to go through.
And I don't know what time you're going to spend on that. So Dr. Cutters, you have any recommendations for intermittent fasting and food, cabiting.
What should a breast cancer patient eat proteins, carbohydrates, grains and fruits and when.
So you should eat what we recommended you eat on your cheek swab test.
So if you're a cheek swab test, we told you to stay away from dairy, which is common for breast cancer.
Then, and that was let's let's say let's pretend to make it simple. That was your only restriction is to stay away from dairy.
Everything else, nothing else was a driver that's pretend only dairy was the driver.
Well, you, you know, you do, we give you that whole green section because, you know, not everybody's familiar with yeah, we got to try to eat organic and we got to stay away from sugar.
And we got it, you know, that, you know, all the other things that we ask you to limit and to be careful with.
And then there is another stage there's another step you could everybody could go because we're only testing the cheek swab and there was the only way to do it is to test we lock into cancer and then see.
What I think is a driver or what I think you should stay away from for cancer, but there's no way to test whether you with the cheek swab, whether you have antibodies to other foods that's why.
You know, I'm so excited for my answer patients to go and look at the new course I have an auto view disease because that goes into depth on my teaching about looking and why you'd want to.
Look at antibodies to foods as well, do I have antibodies to do I have self antibodies and I wrote way back when I first wrote my first, first, first writing stop fighting cancer start treating the cause over 10 years ago I wrote that I believe cancer has an auto view component.
And so that's why I've been just so driven to study auto view disease and all the latest information of auto view diseases is in that course so there.
So the next stage and say I can't tested I've been staying away from dairy in fact to this question what else could I do you know I'm still having other health issues maybe it's not even related to the cancer well the next step is to do some antibody testing.
And it's in that course in the second module where you start digging into what other testing should you do you could test for anti your you know like there's another question about parasites in here is that that person obviously maybe concerned with parasites you could do parasite testing we could do stool parasite testing we could do.
Which would I think would be more common with cancer issues is microtoxin testing microtoxins are for mold so mold exposure we could do glyphosate testing which is probably the most common with cancer you're exposed to pesticides and herbicides and you know that be something to look at now that those things just tell you you know what things that we need to continue to work on to detox we already know those things so there's no.
Need to do those testing that deeper thing that i'm talking about is do antibody testing to other foods because I may be you know gluten might not be driving my cancer but if it's driving inflammatory state that it's very secondary tertiary way could be driving a cancer or driving any other disease so.
Looking at antibody testing whether you do a Syrex to 3x4 or Syrex 10 those are food antibodies looking at tissue antibody testing which is a Syrex 5 if this is going over most people's heads right now if you haven't looked at that course but I go into detail why you want to do those tests and I know it's.
A lot of meeting that course but if you could plow through that stuff and I'm adding stuff to that course all the time you can plow through that stuff that will really help you understand oh wow maybe this is the next step of what I could be missing and that could be another piece to my cancer remember cancer is very complex and it's and it's multi faceted so if I can deal with it as many different facets as possible I'm going to have a better success.
So make sure you take the time to look at that if you can hunter counters and all the clinic they could for your work I have not been diagnosed or told that my breast cancer is a task to size to my bones but would it be helpful for my right to be programmed for that just in case.
Yeah you can I mean yes yes and no I if you if if you had no clue and that it wasn't that it was the task to size and you had no.
In clean that it would be do we really need to add some bone building frequencies and such into their world we're stealing a little bit of time away from the cancer killing frequencies so.
I don't put bone building frequencies in everybody's program if there's no known the test is this if after I talk to that person on the phone on their case review and there and then or you know they send it to cheek swap when we had a communication link that we think the cancer is growing many times I will test with the cheek swap will all put i'll change that person's program so that's why.
Some of you may have gotten a flash drive when you get your cheek swap test on because I tweaked the program it may times is because I put some metastatic frequencies in there to help with bone building or something like that so.
But just as a preventive thing maybe if you feel in your heart that maybe that's what you know how God's kind of lead you then I would say there's nothing wrong with doing that so.
But if that's not in your mind at all you're just thinking well.
You're just asking the question and I'd say maybe maybe wait on them.
Also I did the take Astro clear aroma clear and so for as I'm instead of let us all which is again the robot a inhibitor drug which has which let us all has caused my bones to ache and my eyes to become so dry that it's putting.
I drop to my eyes all day long yeah there's a lot of side effects to the to the aroma taste inhibitors my question is how much of each and I take okay so i'm just looking at this question now so really i'll have to email you again I should have made a recommendation so you should look at your email back at your emails.
If I made those recommendations take those things I made recommendations for the numbers to take but I'll look back and i'll try to remember to email you again that if I did to do that.
I also mentioned before that I take the ingredients out of the capsules so that you're not getting a cell you'll also the cell caps yeah that's good.
Also where is the best placement for my right ball during the night well if you have breast cancer it's right up by your chest by your abdomen that's the best placement really for almost every cancer so you're snuggling with that ball how far away from my body and how dear to the breast.
Again the closer it can be to you the better i'll certainly some people are like really bothered with the ball next to them which is bothers them it keeps them awake well that's where by the amplifier from true right can be a benefit that you could put the ball under the bed.
So that's another option for people for the few people at that bottoms okay questions that came in here.
If someone is trying to eat a low history diet is it okay to use the chocolate flavored greens first or is that problematic.
But what you're getting at a scoop of the greens first how much cocoa you're getting in there I don't think that's a problem.
I don't think that's a problem at all there's not just the much history in that.
I had the same question as them I really dislike the mid flavor greens first yep we get that I understand that.
I personally liked the mid flavor some people hate that my son hates me so he uses the chocolate flavor what he does that so.
And it's an ice that they you know the chocolate flavor is the same price because it's you know if you felt the weight of the two jugs it's all flavors twice it's heavy so.
Is there another brand that's just as good there's a lot of brands of greens out there and believe me we wanted to private label our old greens.
Honestly the other stuff that I've tried either just doesn't have the same about a stuff in it.
And or it's just so awful tasty so you know we just you know when a company comes out hey you know they said be a bottle of their greens they want me to try it.
And I just I just have stayed all these years we've stayed with greens first because I just think it's the best product so again i'm trying to use the best product for everybody that just because we can private label we're trying to private label only the best product so greens first doesn't allow private label I'd rather use their use the better product so.
Is bird man vegan protein powder okay I don't know I don't know what bird man vegan protein powder is I could look it up here.
But hold on.
All right bird man balcony shy is that one of this bird man i've never seen this one got a it's a blue with a bird man child balcony shy vegan protein powder interesting.
I'm looking at the reason why so the reason why I recommend the US enzyme protein powder is that it's low in glutinine and it's hard to tell how much glutinabit is in this is the label that I have is.
From when we're selling this is not very good I'd have to do it more deeper dive on that to give you.
A matter editor.
Lutamic acid listed on protein powder is the same as glutamine yes it breaks down the glutamine yes yes it is.
Reading your email this week on glucose glutamine seemed like going light on glutamine was a good idea I have been not been told the restrict protein in my diet would should I be worried about it so.
I recommend that anybody with cancer never takes excess glutamine why would you take excess glutamine well if you're taking a lot if you're using a lot of protein powder.
You're going to get some glutamine because.
But if it's a balanced protein powder you're not going to get a ton of glutamine where are you going to get the most glutamine is in a supplement for your gut so got healing supplements are going to be very high in glutamine about a glutamine in this bird man powder most likely is maybe 300 milligrams most likely maximum.
Maybe far less than that.
But there's there's.
God healing products that are being high in glutamine purposefully why because glutamine drives growth.
And that's why it can be really really good to heal your gut quickly it drives growth glutamine is what epithelial cells really feed off up so it can really help heal the gut.
The damage got leaky gut syndrome is because there's a gap in the I got epithelial cell cell has died so you're really reproducing gut cells so that you could heal those wounds in the gut those those.
The tight junctions that have been opened up because of damage gut cells so what makes sense well why should everybody be a glutamine because glutamine drives growth and if you have answered you certainly do not want to drive growth of any kind.
And secondly there's there's other negatives to be not a glutamine product too.
That has nothing to do with cancer so if you have a lot of.
If you have a gene defects then you are going to convert glutamine to glutamate quite readily and glutamate is an excitatory neurotransmitter and that can cause muscle twitching muscle spasms.
It's very serious in that it functions in the brain as an excitatory neurotransmitter which causes an increase anxiety increases ADD increases ADHD and good as eggs we kind of have an epidemic of that in our society, but it's partly because the food processing companies what glutamates in the food because glutamates.
They inspire on receptors on your tongue excitatory neurotransmitters in the brain that cause an increase in uptake of excitement in the brain literally you can see on a functional MRI your brain is literally light up when you put glutamates on your tongue.
And that actually makes you think this food tastes so good.
So the pleasure that you get from eating something with a lot of glutamates is increased you get this excitatory spike kind of like a dopamine spike that you get from you know reading emails or getting a rudder is high.
You get this glutamate spike but it can be very damaging to the right it can actually cause an increase and glutamate receptors on your neurons that never go away and you can really cause a lot of damage to this person can be that very prone to you know anxiety and OCD tendencies.
That is literally what OCD and anxiety is is really a glutamate issue 99% of the time so adding exogenous glutamates are causing this issue and making it even worse for these people.
Adding exogenous glutamate if you have a lot of there's several different genes can genes are just one of them you will break down glutamate the amino acid into glutamate quite quickly way faster than you will spike your glutamates as well so.
There's some yeah there's some benefit to using glutamate in a nutritional supplement if you do not have cancer and you have leaky gut but still even that I would only do that a very short period of time I personally so if I have a non cancer patient and they have leaky gut issues and we're going to try to heal their leaky gut I will use our clear GI product.
And that is is got glutamated if it's got a whole bunch of other slippery element a whole bunch of other really good nutrients to help heal the gut but it's only got it's got less than a gram of glutamate so a lot of gut healing products will have five four or five grams of glutamate I think it's very dangerous playing with that I just don't think it's a good idea.
Even if you don't have cancer and a lot of people have cancer they don't know they have cancer that they're just like pouring fire on the cancer fuel gasoline on a fire that they don't even know is burning so it's very dangerous.
Okay finish this question our seaweed enemy enemy is good well I am going to say no to that so.
So seaweed is going to be very high in iodine and you know I'm all for using iodine for a short period of time with breast cancer and especially topically can be beneficial but long term iodine use and is going to you know definitely affect the thyroid negatively.
And so go back to the auto view course go to module I don't know the last module the module a Hashimoto said you'll hear the truth about iodine with that I don't know if I would use I would use seaweed animals.
I'll look more on this bird man chocolate thing.
What combination do I order if I want.
Do I order if I want to take bed is all for parasites will combination the order so if you're going to use a bed is all for cancer typically you're using only a packet of that a day.
And certainly that can bet that can be good for some parasites if you really think you have parasites we have a new product from PHP called our new this is our new pair of clear it is just you look it up on our website the pair of clear.
I've used that product before we had a private label it's the same thing is the prover with huge I think that's just been our favorite parasite killer parasites are super super common and non cancer patients can have issues and parasites so we use that prover with huge I would look at that before I would go on even the bed is all for parasite.
I would do an herbal.
The topic I said yes I talked about that is taking glucose glutamate seem to be light on the glutamate yeah it's out you're going to get glutamate you're you're going you need glutamate it's you that's essential amino acid but you don't need you know access amounts of it so you're going to get glutamated you're in your meat of your vegetable protein.
So they're all with glutamate it's just that access about that spike of glutamate you're taking like three to five grams of glutamate in a product I think there's danger.
I would have any of you doing that so I just actually had a cheap swamp from somebody that has started with us a long time ago and has not been in contact with us for a long long time and.
The person was doing glutamated it's like what we told you to do that not us wasn't our product we don't even have product with high glutamated so well we actually do but we don't carry any.
If I choose to do a vitamin C IV's what milligram do I start with so you're you want to take the advice of the IV center but they're going to push you to do high dose I don't think it's ever good to start there.
So if you start with 20 grams it depends so they buy the packs in certain at certain milligrams sets so it might be a 20,000 milligram then they'll go to 40 then they'll go to 60 then they'll go to 80 or it's 25 to 50 to 75.
So it depends on how they have their set so I can't say do 15,000 or 15 grams if they don't buy bags of 15 grams the lowest they have is 25 grams certainly do not start more than 25 grams that you work up to 50 to 75 grams partly it depends on your weight.
So you know if you're you know 140 pounds maybe the most you're going to do is 50 grams if you're 240 pounds maybe you'll go up to 75 grams I've had people that said they're higher than that but I don't think there's any evidence that that's necessary.
This sun warrior protein is pea protein and it has 28 80 milligrams of glutamic acid yeah that's too high.
So that's in my opinion too high first of all you have to ask yourself the question why are you taking protein powder so that that would be my first question to anybody who's asking the question about protein powder.
Why do you feel like you need to take protein powder you know I personally have never felt like I needed to take protein powder and protein powder is not the thing that's going to make you gain weight you don't gain weight because you eat a lot protein.
If the only reason I would think that a cancer patient should take protein powder is if they're getting a lot of muscle loss so if they're in a cacacic state they're getting a lot of muscle loss then taking a protein powder might be a good option to do so if they're not getting muscle loss then I don't think if you're eating well then you don't really need a protein powder.
Remember if you're getting muscle loss you have to watch my video on cacacia and look at the blog post on cacacia because you need to be doing some ways you need to be stimulating muscle growth so muscle is only going to grow when you ask something of it when you're calling action of that muscle which is you're using it.
So if I'm so sick that I'm just laying in bed and can't do anything you're going to have muscle atrophy even if you're taking protein powder you're still going to have muscle atrophy so you the only way that you could not have muscle atrophy is you need to use the muscle.
So you could be using the muscle and lifting weights and still have muscle atrophy you're still losing muscle cells because you have to caccia the cancers just gobbling up anything you have that's when it to me is appropriate to take protein powder so if you're just taking you just have surgery and you're going to be on a protein powder and still I wouldn't if you're still if you're eating well and you're eating fish and you're eating meat that's if you're a if you're a vegan you're not getting any.
In vegetable protein either well then maybe you have to because you're on a diet that's restricting protein then it's maybe appropriate but it that it's trying to defeat the purpose of your diet restricting protein if you're taking protein powder so but if you're still just trying to oh i'm just trying to restrict animal proteins well then I can't get enough in my diet a vegetable protein so i'm trying to take protein powder well I guess there's reasons for this.
So you got everybody's different you got to weigh this on weigh this on he had muscle lost this was before the treatment we have to start from square one once he could eat solid food again that's right so he can't eat that so you're getting protein through a powder I would look at the US enzymes protein has a much lower the atomic acid content.
Not your counters what is your breakfast or lunch daily well some things I just don't disclose don't just kidding so it depends so if I if it's a work day and I'm going to work typically I do not eat breakfast so I try to do intermittent fasting but again i'm not like stick and not a stick to it on anything with that.
If I'm going to be at home and I'm going to be out working in the garden it's in the summertime and I'm going to be busy I'm honestly if I'm busy I just do not have hunger and if when I get hungry it's because I am sitting around not doing anything at home when it's in the middle of the winter I tend to put on a weight in the winter and I lose it in the summer so I have about 30 pounds to lose right now so.
I am hopeful that you know when gardening season starts which we had some really nice weather we can go now cold again I'll be out burning these calories because I just I just will go out work and I'll just work all day outside and my wife and I don't cut it until it's dark and because we just love doing that so it's sometimes I'll go without breakfast and lunch and I have no problem with that because I need to burn calories.
And that's my intermittent fasting day so that's my time restricted eating day then i'll eat when we get back in the house but every day is not the same for me every day is very different for me so there's times that I'll eat breakfast if we're doing something and we're together we might have eggs in the winter I like to eat oatmeal.
But yeah that's typical breakfast and lunch varies completely how often do I do vitamin C and weigh 96 pounds and a five one so yeah if you're going to do vitamin C IVs 96 pounds you got to ask them for a bag no I would be careful starting anymore than 20 grams and I would probably only start once a week.
So you're pretty TV with glutathione yep you can use glutathione transfer factor for cancer patients yes try to remember what it is though.
There's and the confusing part for me on try to recall that is that there's a number of supplements that are called that have that are transfer factor to so I'd have to dig into that again.
I don't know if I've ever written a vlog on that or not.
Yeah I don't know I don't know i'll have to look that up again I apologize.
thoughts on ozone IV.
i'm not a big fan of ozone IV for cancer I don't think that is.
Most I don't think it's a negative necessarily with it but it's to me ozone IV or the benefits of that is if you have like right disease so a bacterial infection that seems more appropriate.
All right thank you for that link i'll look that up what that is again how to decrease cancer that may have been fueled in the past month by the glutamine in the protein powder.
So it's pretty hard to say that okay I was eating poorly this past month or something could that have made my cancer grow really crazy.
There's just too many factors to like point the believe it one thing ever so i'd be careful not to do that first of all so let's say you know let's say you a person's cancer grew really quick you know in the last 60 days and they go i've been able to do that.
The way off my diet that's really it well you can't say that you just don't know what factors are involved with growth it's not always diet it's not always you know why it was eating glutamine that's the reason so don't get me wrong don't don't just because I said you should be eating glutamine if you have cancer doesn't be that it's good to grow like crazy for a person that has cancer.
That has cancer it's not that is necessarily good to be the cause of the factor of that so just you can't take that dogmatic and.
It's and exact there's it's there's not perfect scenario there so don't beat yourself up about about that.
i'm just saying this we got to use wisdom in all our decision making processes and if I have a cancer i'm not going to be taking an exogenous glutamate powder you know that could be a fuel source right i'm just going to be wise.
it's just like okay if I have a cancer that's growing I need to clean up my diet but to be honest I have patients that some of you might be in this category I don't know but I have I've had patients over the years.
Let them come to me and say hey i'll do the right thing i'll take a few supplements but I ain't changing my diet one I order I just want to let you know that typically it's a guy and it's like good is safe they got better so it's like.
So is diet important yeah I think diet support isn't you know always important no so it just just keep that in mind you know if you do have cancer growth over a period of time how can I do you do everything you know what to do to put the breaks on it that's the answer to that question.
Don't start you know second guessing yourself with beating yourself up and blaming yourself and you know you don't blame me to practitioner that put you on something or don't I just think there's not health in that so.
Okay it is what it is i'm going to learn something new and when you learn something new you try to apply that thing new you don't go back in time and and cause guilt and shame or anything else that.
Could be doing so just make sure you're not doing that.
Where can I get rick Simpson oil that is good quality.
It's all over now so the rick you can get rick Simpson oil and Betty states legally.
I know you can get rick Simpson oil and a lot of the.
A lot of the a lot of the dispensaries in any legal state but you have right at the goal there there's places online that you can get rick Simpson oil through Facebook there's a some Facebook pages on rick Simpson oil to search for those two.
And if you go to some of the Facebook cancer groups are some of the.
Other cancer groups that might be in some of the other chat what do you call it.
Apps that are out there there's people that are that are nowhere to get rick Simpson oil so we cannot legally supply rick Simpson oil so.
Any other question okay well.
Thank you guys i'll be praying for you and hopefully it's sunny where you are get out and bake yourself in the sun joy life.
Always when you're stressed about your cancer stuff I'm reminded her.
There's a lot of cases of like I said patients that I've had over the years that are just said you know just going to do everything they can do and they're going to just leave the results to God and trust him that's what I want for all of you guys so.
Just try to live that life as best you possibly can go i'll be praying for you.
Ask God for the peace to pass us all understanding and all you're the simple will be processes and i'll see you guys next week.